ان شاء الله صلاه العشاء
8 صلاه العشاء اقامه العشاء بدءا من
الليله على تمام الثامنه والنصف ان شاء
الله صلاه العشاء بدءا من الليله
على تمام الثامنه والنصف ان شاء الله
تعالى
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
فالدرس موصول
في كتاب رياض الصالحين
من كلام سيد سيد المرسلين للحافظ الفقيه
ابي زكريا يحيى ابن شرف النووي رحمه الله
تعالى رحمه واسعه في الباب الاول الحديث
الرابع
رياض الصالحين
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى
باب الاخلاص واحضار النيه
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول عن ابي عبد الله
جابر بن عبد الله الانصاري
رضي الله عنهما
قال كنا مع النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في
غزاه
فقال ان بالمدينه لرجالا ما سرتم مسيرا
ولا قطعتم واديا الا كانوا معكم حبسهم
المرض وفي روايه الا شركوكم في الاجر رواه
مسلم ورواه البخاري عن انس رضي الله عنه
قال
يفهم من كلام المؤلف رحمه الله ان الروايه
اذا جاءت حتى ولو بنفس اللفظ عند البخاري
واختلف الراوي عند مسلم ولو اتحد اللفظ
فانه يعتبر حديثين لا يعتبر متفق عليه
متفق عليه لابد ان يتحد الراوي الراوي
الذي هو الصحابي
فاذا جاء عن نفس الصحابي ولو اختلف اللفظ
واتحد المعنى كان متفقا عليه
واذا اختلف اللفظ مع اتحاد المعنى واختلف
الراوي ولو اتفق اللفظ مع اختلاف الراوي
فانه يكون
ليس من باب المتفق عليه فهنا عن جابر بن
عبد الله عند مسلم
ثم عند البخاري عن انس رضي الله عنه فلم
يقل المؤلف متفق عليه وانما قال هذا لمسلم
وهذا للبخاري قال ورواه البخاري عن انس
رضي الله عنه قال رجعنا من غزوه تبوك مع
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال ان اقواما
خلف فنا بالمدينه
ما سلكنا شعبا ولا واديا الا وهم معنا
حبسهم العذر
هل من الممكن
ان تكون هذه وقعتان يعني قال هذا وسمعه
جابر وقال ذاك وسمعه انس يمكن لكن يستبعد
هذا خاصه وان انسا وجابرا كلاهما ما شهد
تبوك ف الراجح والظاهر
انه ما سمع النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
هذا وحفظاه بالمعنى او من بعدهما
فجاءت الروايه عن جابر وجاءت الروايه عن
انس لكن بالجمع بينهما نعرف ان هذه كانت
في غزوه تبوك
ابي عبد الله جابر بن عبد الله رضي الله
عنه وعن ابيه
رضي الله عنهما
احد
جابر رضي الله
جابر رضي الله عنه
[Silence]
عبد الله الانصاري
رضي الله عنه استشهد يوم احد
جابر رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
‏How did he go to himself
during his time in
the time of the growing Muslim state? We
would find that in the correct opinion
of the historians and biographers
he was at 18 battles
غسائ النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
جابر الله
احد
رضي الله عنه انس رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ام سليم انس رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم انس
صلى الله عليه وسلم
arrived
‏was
صلى الله عليه وسلم مدين
انس رضي الله عنه
جابر رضي الله عنه
جابر انس
صلى الله عليه
تبوك
انء الله
كعبنك
صلى الله عليه وسلم سال
ان بالمدينه لرجالا
ان مدينه ما سرتم مسيرا ولا قطعتم وادي
الا كانوا معكم
[Silence]
تبوك
صلى الله عليه وسلم
حبسهم المرض
‏ill
some that ill there some who to po to jo
they have any way of getting from the
battle they have any way theavan so they
had the intention to go but the decree
of was the only between them and their
effort.
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان شاء الله تعالى
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا